well after the Prime Minister laid the
ground for a potential delay to ask for
50 leaving the European Union what a
hard-line conservative brexit ears make
of these developments a few minutes ago
I spoke to the chair of the European
research group Jacob Riis MOG asking him
whether he'll now back the prime
ministers deal in order to say brigs it
we won't I wouldn't have thought to put
the deal as it stands I think the real
problem is the backstop because it
doesn't have an end date it's permanent
and it would leave us bound into EU
rules in an island to a customs union
and two barriers between northern and
Great Britain and that doesn't work it
won't work so as long as that is there
this deal will not get the support of
the bulk of your sceptics but if there
were to be moves on the backstop you
might change your position I mean and
that doesn't necessarily have to be in
the withdrawal agreement itself as I
understand it it has to have equal
weight to the withdrawal agreement so if
it were to be an appendix that would be
satisfactory but then the backstop is
itself an appendix so you can add to the
withdrawal agreement without reopening
it it seems to me so that would work but
it must be of equal legal standing does
seem to me strange position that you who
campaign for briggsie for so long and
now potentially voting down a deal which
would take Britain out on March the 29th
whereas a lot of people Daniel thinking
starts making this point in The Times
today who were reluctant about breaks it
and now supporting that idea well that's
because a lot of people who are
reluctant about breaks it like a deal
that doesn't really take us out of the
European eunuchs they never wanted to
leave in the first place whereas we want
to leave properly and what's quite
interesting about this delay if it would
have happened is that we would still
face the same position at the end of
June unless there is a deal that can get
through Parliament but does conceivably
allow that is maybe a pass hope for the
Malthouse compromise to replace the
Irish backstop because there's now time
to discuss and agree that whereas there
probably wasn't time to do that before
but does that mean you're warming to the
idea of a short delay no it doesn't it
means that there may be a silver lining
you you wouldn't vote for Italy oh no of
course not no no I'd be much happier to
leave on 29th March which is what 17
and four million people are expecting us
to do people say again and again they
voted to leave not for a deal that's
really important and there is a
disconnection between members of
parliament and the electorate that about
500 of the 650 MPs basically a
remainders but the country at large for
a majority voted to leave and that is
quite troubling in terms of British
political life because the elected and
the electors are not as one and we do
know there's fairly widespread fear
concern of the consequences of what some
people call crashing out of leaving
without a deal on the 29th there's been
a lot of reports suggesting that could
be very dire consequences II you
prepared to inflict that on your
constituents well we've had an enormous
amount of dire reports coming out
particularly of the Treasury which were
all been nonsense very mind we were
going to have a punishment budget we
were going to have unemployment rise
between five hundred eight hundred
thousand now this happened we're record
levels of impact was a hypothetical
where nothing was changing I mean all
the twenty-ninth if we leave things will
change one day well it wasn't a
hypothetical it was economic predictions
being made by the Treasury on the basis
of what they knew at the time the
argument is your friend the governor of
the Bank of England actually took the
steps which avoided that economic impact
but before we left he said he might have
to put interest rates up and there would
be recession but he must have known what
he could do he did take some he took
some steps but he made forecasts
beforehand as to what would happen in
the knowledge of the past about you
you're prepared to gamble with the
livelihoods of your constituents by
plunging them into a neural bridge but
what you have highlighted about the
governor of the Bank of England shows
the politicization of the information he
was given because he was ignoring the
ability he had to change things no it's
not a gamble that what he's going to
happen afterwards is that we will carry
on trading with the European Union that
Calais and Ava have both said they will
keep the port ape and it will be under
our control as to what level of tariffs
we impose dozens of countries around the
world over 150 countries around the
world are not members of the Union and
they for example we might impose tariffs
I mean that seems to be the government
plan which will lead to significant
increases in prices of agricultural
goods which I mean your constituents
would be out of pocket that would be
completely stupid thing to do I would
rate against tariffs of that kind that
we should not be imposing tariffs on
people making their lives poorer we
should use this an opportunity to cut
the cost of food clothing and footwear
and improve the standard of living of
the British people one of the exciting
opportunities of brexit time is pressing
what what do you think is going to
happen oh I think it is likely that
there will be an extension now I shall
vote against it and we may be having a
very similar conversation in late June
okay thank you smoke thank you very much
indeed for your time